ae a casa do tempo de agora
i ó até a rua pac matias havendo esse
papel aqui que tem a assinatura desse
contrato
fui eu que assinei eu sou eu trago
coletivo mas eu vou explicar e tudo a
vida a ação um homem que se passou aqui
e propôs pagar nossas dívidas furtam
kush atores e até com a prefeitura isso
não é formada por mais eu gosto e
meditar annan
eu primeiro assunto ei eu a criei eu
escutar propostas e as nossas políticas
mas um sap sal mas um saco de carvão mas
uma peça de picanha teste tamanho como a
gordura que vêm até aqui teve alta
cultura homem deixa amanhã o governo e
com a equipe que ganhou não sei que com
a minha assinatura
a gente é só você mateus você não estava
lá dentro de sua parte por você o que
foi essa pai e não diz que o homem era
esquisito junto à 1ª via do contrato
ele levou minha sombra como sinal
sua sombra eu também estranhei pau cabra
baixo e rolou miasson guardou no paletó
e foi embora e eu respondo a gente tem
tanta coisa que não precisa a sombra
pente pela chuva pelo menos é o que a
pessoa a quem visita o local
se eu soubesse que eu já vendi lugar uma
por capeta eu tinha perdido duas peças
de picanha você brincar com estranho mas
eu tô falando sério uma peça a uma queda
valor fica bem
hoje é também ter alma por qualquer pra
conseguir um cargo público aparecer na
mídia e além do mais não vem da alma não
eu vender a sua assinatura e taiba esta
área o contrato eu conheci um cara o
nome dele é jesus mas ele pode te vou
ver a minha sombra e vou ver sua alma e
o mais importante ele promete o reino da
fartura disso é só uma pega seu carro na
bahia mas já era tarde demais
foi o brasileiro jesus ainda era noite
quando eles chegaram nem sempre chegam à
noite enquanto estamos atentos enquanto
estamos com solo chegaram a um macaco
mais rápida do assalto ajuda à frente
o beijo que no curto tempo do nosso
espanto levaram jesus
ai ai ai ai ai ai ai
aí a não chorei por mim e com a minha
coragem sustento meu medo da jornada por
minha própria escolha
eu sou judas você já sabe por 30 moedas
eu traí minha fé não não seja tão
apressado me condenar olhe para dentro
de mim me veja eu sou um homem que
guarda uma profunda feia a dor humana
mas quem sou eu o que são todos os
homens serão confusão em razão de crime
criança de redenção porque é que eu não
posso levantar e me abaixei essa aturar
ball e por vossos filhos e sobretudo no
time se o tempo em que inúmeros qualquer
choro e qualquer lutar
o laço já se fechou e um homem o homem
morto é eco vai morrer você também
i ele a voz a washington a corda até a
rua é é acaba olha é o gol da igualdade
bola eu e amigos ok andré e bahia
a aip surf dado a maria madalena é bom
mas ele disse que voltaria ele disse que
votaria em ninguém bota e chapéu e bota
abre alas que eu quero passar hoje
agora eu tenho a palavra queria saber
jesus volta ou não volta porque olha eu
creio eu creio eu quero crer que ele
volta e ele prometeu que da fartura não
eu tenho toda e qualquer coisa porque a
gente como eu tem mais nada a perder não
em sombra mas eu tenho dó de mim só que
estamos vendo aqui então o que sobra pra
gente que nem eu senão emoção sempre bem
fé sabe essas coisas que não têm preço
porque no mundo que a empresa já tem
dono e jeito como já o pt não pode pagar
então é bem qualquer discurso em
qualquer promessa porque primeiro
admitiram tudo e depois me toque de
esperança e como não tenho esperança não
só esperar
eu sinto o creme ou será que ele volta
não é deus não pode tudo
não é ninguém teve coragem de dizer
qualquer coisa joão teité quer dizer até
tinham coisas a dizer mas não quiseram
tirar a última esperança que ainda
restava ave marinha não fez é isso eu
jesus onde jesus quer saber uma coisa
importante é só pro meio da fatura
a fartura está no mundo e todos e têm
direito a uma parte dessa fatura todos e
que a fome seja infinita como ele tem
técnica e midi e de empregar todos da
boa nova é deus veio alvo e ele esse
pessoal
espero o tio uso
me ver eu z na terra que o homem subiu
ao céu caminho saltimbancos a gás a jóia
buscar ganso a história
ai ai galera de estrelas uma fogueira
coração atenção no rio grande do norte
beira a estrela hoje uma fogueira o
coração até incluindo nove beihai cheia
não é isso que é cheia de paixão visual
cheia ao pelotão é isso que cheio o auto
da paixão não